the realm do you know what the realm is
it's the thousand blades of Aegon's
enemies a story we agreed to tell each
other over and over till we forget that
it's a lie
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another a Song of Ice and Fire
Theory video today I want to talk about
arguably one of the most important
scenes in the books which is when the
Starks found the dire wolf pups in the
late summer snows but what I mainly want
to talk about today is how Jon Snow
found his direwolf ghost there are a lot
of different theories surrounding that
scene but I don't recall any videos
about the theory I want to discuss with
you today there is one thing that I
always found very interesting and some
of you might not actually know this but
the entire story was essentially
inspired by that scene when the Starks
find the direwolves before george RR
martin had ever worked the first book a
game of Thrones this was the very first
scene that actually popped in his head
this creation began back in 1991 and I
know that's a while ago but I'm hoping
you can remember for us the scene or the
image that launched this series a Song
of Ice and Fire
it was the it was the first chapter of
the novel Game of Thrones not not the
prologue which actually appears first I
brought that later but it was the the
chapter where they brand viewpoint and
they write up to see the the desert have
beheaded and then they find the dire
wolf pups and in the summer snow as you
can see this is a moment in the story
that has to be very near and dear to the
author's heart because it was the scene
that led to him creating one of the
greatest stories of our time this is
also a very significant moment because
this actually foreshadows a number of
different events of that what happened
much later in the story the dead stag in
dire wolf was a perfect representation
of what would eventually happen to house
Baratheon and House Stark but most
importantly these pups would later go on
to save the stark children on a number
of different occasions
most people would even say that the
names of each dire wolf foreshadows the
fate of each of the stark children so
it's quite clear that this scene was
very significant to the overall story
now this obviously makes most of us
wonder did the Starks find these dire
wolves by accident or were the Starks
meant to have them like Jon Snow said
the Ned's
Dark Lord stuff there are five pups one
for each of the stark children the
direwolf is the sigil of your house at
this point many people believe they were
gifted from the old gods of the north
some people think Bloodraven and the
children of the forest sent the Starks
their direwolves but there are other
people that believe that could have even
been brain stark that played a part in
this in my opinion I would be willing to
accept either one of those theories
because both of them make a lot of sense
for many different reasons but as I said
before today I want to focus on how Jon
Snow actually found ghosts I don't
necessarily want to focus on how a
direwolf made it south of the wall I
want to focus on what actually made Jon
Snow go back and look a second time
because that was what led to Jon finding
ghosts I'm sure all of you remember the
scene from the TV show but I know some
of you haven't been able to read the
books yet I think some of you may find
this evidence to be very interesting
because I know I do the theory I want to
propose today is bran Stark from the
future assisted Jon Snow and finding
ghosts let me repeat that bran Stark
from the future assisted Jon Snow and
finding ghosts now does that sound crazy
well let me explain what I want to do
first to show you a couple different
quotes that help explain why the Starks
were able to find them in the late
summer snows I think by this point
almost everyone believes someone
connected to the old gods played a very
big part in making sure the Starks found
these pups that day but if you haven't
read the books then you might not know
this in order to believe this the first
thing I would need to do is establish
how it would be possible for someone to
lead a direwolf to that location without
transporting it there physically can
someone actually do this the answer to
that question is yes not only is this
Irving time and time again in the books
but they started to show us this at the
very beginning of the television show we
know that the three-eyed Raven or
Bloodraven can control different animals
we have seen him do this a bunch of
different times we also know that bran
Stark can do this as well we have even
seen the damn night king take control of
many different animals - so now that we
know it is possible for someone to enter
the mind of a pregnant dire wolf and
take us out to the wall we need to
figure out who would want to do this
let's take a look at some of the quotes
from the books
because I think it becomes quite obvious
that someone connected to the old gods
did have something to do with this some
of the best evidence actually comes to
us through Catelyn Stark's chapters the
first quote says that is no common wolf
that one the great John's been hard to
say that the old gods of the north sent
those dire wolves do your children
Catelyn remembered the day when her boys
had found the pups in the late summer
snows there had been five three male and
two female for the five true born
children of House Stark in a sixth white
a fir and red a vie for Ned's bastard
son Jon Snow no common wolves she
thought no indeed when you think about
it what are the odds that the Starks
would find just enough dire wolves for
each of the children not only were they
exactly enough but the sex of each of
the direwolf was a perfect match with
their owner Jon bran robb and Rickon all
had male dire wolves where Sansa and
Arya both had female dire wolves just
like them that is definitely not a
coincidence in my opinion Catelyn Stark
knew that some higher power had to be at
play because in the next quote she says
any man gray when Miss likes is a man I
do not one close to you these wolves are
more than wolves Rob you must know that
I think that perhaps the gods sent them
to us
your father's gods the old gods of the
North five wolf pups Rob five four five
stark children six said Rob there was a
wolf for John as well I found them
remember Catelyn Stark is not the only
one who starts to think that someone
sent these dire wolves because John snow
starts to consider this as well later in
the books John realizes something
significant about ghost
red eyes John realized but not like
Melisandre s' he had a where woods eyes
red eyes red mouth white fur blood and
bone like a heart tree he belongs to the
old gods and he alone of all the dire
wolves was white six pups they found in
a late summer snows him and Rob five
that were gray and black and brown for
the five Starks and one white as white
as snow as you can see John realizes
ghost belongs to the old gods he has the
exact same colors as a weirwood tree
another very interesting thing worth
noting his ghost doesn't just look like
a weirwood tree but he also resembles
Bloodraven in the mystery night we get a
good description of blood Raven and this
is what it says white is bone were the
skin and hair of run
rivers in his eye he had only the one
the other having been lost to his
half-brother bittersteel when the red
grass field was red his blood blood
raven skin is referred to as white his
bone and his red eye is referred to as
red his blood that's blood and bone like
a heart tree which is exactly what John
said about ghost he is blood and bone
like a heart tree when John thinks about
this he also thinks about the day that
him and Robb I'd found all the pups now
let's go back to that day John found
ghost make sure you pay very close
attention to the details in that scene
because as I said at the beginning of
the video I think brain start from the
future made sure John went back and
found ghost after they find the first
five pups they are getting ready to
leave and head back to Winterfell
but that's until John hear something
that no one else seems to notice let's
take a look at what it says it was not
until they were mounted and on their way
that brain allowed himself to taste the
sweet air of victory by then his pup was
snuggled inside his leathers warm
against him for the safe long ride home
bran was wondering what to name him
halfway across the bridge John pulled up
suddenly what is it John
their Lord father asked can't you hear
it bran could hear the wind in the trees
the clatter of their hooves on the iron
wood planks the whimpering of his hungry
pup but John was listening to something
else now try to remember the details
that we have been told so far they were
already halfway across the bridge with
the large group of horses making a ton
of noise but somehow John heard
something in the distance
John heard something else bran could
hear the wind in the trees don't forget
that line right there because when he
hears the wind in the trees that will
come up later a few times in the video
there John said he swung his horse
around and began to gallop back across
the bridge they watched him dismount
where the direwolf lay dead in the snow
watched him kneel a moment later he was
riding back to them smiling he must have
crawled away from the others John said
all right now let's break this scene
down because there were a few different
interesting things that happened here
the first thing we need to ask is how
the hell did Jon Snow here ghost they
were already halfway across the bridge
by the time John heard something but how
did he hear ghosts when he is traveling
with a large group of men that are all
riding on horses Moran said all he could
hear was the wind and the sound of all
the
platter of the horses hooves on the iron
wood planks of the bridge but somehow
John was able to hear this tiny pup make
a noise that seems like it would be very
hard to do I find this even more
interesting because we eventually do
learn one thing about ghosts that is
different from all the other dire wolves
they found that day the one special
thing about ghost is he never makes his
sound let's take a look at what John
says in his very first chapter he's not
like the others John said he never makes
his sound that's why I named him ghost
that and because he's white the others
are all dark grey or black let's look at
another quote from one of John's
chapters as he went to his knees
ghost lifted his head his neck glistened
wetly but he made no sound when John
peeled off the glove and touched him
then we get another quote in a storm of
swords atop the stones of the ring wall
ghosts hunched with his white fur
bristling he made no sound but his dark
red I spoke blood then we get another
quote in a clash of kings ghost was
trotting along beside John's horse with
his tail held high
his white fur roughed up thick against
the rain he moved so silently John could
not have said just when he appeared and
here is another quote in the first book
a game of Thrones
ghost was with him he knew that much the
silent presence of the direwolf gave him
comfort almost every single time ghost
is described in the books one of two
things are always mentioned he makes no
sound and he moves silently besides John
whenever they walk there are dozens and
dozens of quotes that remind us ghost
never makes a sound so how the hell did
John hear ghosts of the day he found him
what did John actually hear that made
him turn his horse around after he was
already halfway across the bridge I
highly doubt that he heard this tiny
direwolf pot moving around with all the
noise already coming from the horses
that day something else had to have
happened in my opinion well let's go
back to that scene because brain stark
did say he heard something and he wasn't
just referring to the horses it was not
until they were mounted and on their way
that brain allowed himself to taste the
sweet air of victory by then his pup was
snuggled inside his leathers warm
against him safe for the long ride home
bran was wondering what to name him
halfway across the bridge John pulled up
suddenly what is it John
their Lord father asked
can't you hear it brain could hear the
wind in the trees okay so after Ned says
what is it John John says can't you hear
it that is immediately followed up by
brain thinking about what he does here
and the first thing brain thinks of is
he can hear the wind in the trees
now what does that mean why is that
significant why did the author describe
that to us you also cannot forget this
was the very first scene that george RR
martin had ever written for the story
everything else that happens in the
story originated from this very scene
all right now let's think about a few
different things that John could have
possibly heard that made him turn around
and find ghosts
besides the sounds of the horses were
making that day all we are told is there
was the sound of the wind moving through
the trees so that's all we really have
to go on at this point so if there was
some magical or mystical force
influencing John to turn around and
double check most people would probably
assume it was either bloodraven and/or
the children of the forest since most
people assume they sent the direwolves
in the first place but when it comes to
John finding ghosts by himself I think
something else was at play another thing
you could say is maybe John already had
a close connection to ghosts and that
was what led him to finding the direwolf
in the TV show we never really see John
go inside a ghost but John is able to do
this in the books there are a number of
different quotes that let us know John
is able to sense ghosts whenever he is
nearby here is one of those quotes ghost
was not always with them but he was
never far either even when they were
apart John sensed his nearness he was
glad for that John and ghosts have a
very special bond than the books so if
you want to say John turned around and
found ghost because he could have sensed
him I am completely fine with that
I really can't dispute that because
there is a overwhelming amount of
evidence that shows us this is true we
also know that ghost was the very first
direwolf to open up his eyes they were
actually already open when John found
him
so perhaps John was able to have a
connection to ghost of that day because
of this this is what we are told when
John finds him his fur was white where
the rest of the litter was gray his eyes
were as red as the blood of the ragged
man who had died that morning brain
thought it was curious that this pup
alone would have opened
sighs while the others were still blind
that could explain how John was able to
sense ghosts was there because I don't
think John would have heard him based on
some of the other quotes I have shown
you already ghost is known for always
being silent but since ghost was a first
pup to open up his eyes then perhaps
John was the first one to have a
connection to his direwolf however I
want to go with the third option since
they found the dire wolf pups during one
of bran Starks POV chapters I tend to
believe that bran may have had something
to do with this not to mention the first
thing brain hears that day is the wind
moving through the trees and I think we
are told that for a very good reason
what if I told you it was actually brain
stark from the future making the wind
move through the trees that day could it
have actually been brand that was
influencing John to turn around and find
ghosts I really think John may have
heard a whisper a whisper that caused
him to turn around and that whisper may
have actually came from bran
before you completely disregard this
option let's just take a look at some of
the evidence there is some evidence that
may be suggesting brain stark is trying
to communicate with people for the trees
and the sound of the wind some of you
may or may not remember this but a few
months ago I read one of brains chapters
when he was inside a blood Ravens cave
this is when brain stark begins to learn
how to use the weirwood net by looking
out through the trees his training
begins with him looking through the
heart tree at his home in Winterfell the
first thing he sees is something that
happened very recently because he sees
his father but he is also able to look
back even farther in time because he
sees Leon and benjin playing in the
godswood he sees old nan when she is
much younger and he even sees a vision
that might have took place roughly 8,000
years ago when Winterfell was first
built the vision that I want to focus on
is when brand sees his father Ned
because something very interesting
happens during that vision and it might
explain why bran heard the wind moving
through the trees the day John found
Ghost when Bryan goes inside of the
weirwood net for the first time this is
what happens Lord Eddard Stark set upon
a rock besides the deep black pull in
the godswood the pale roots of the heart
tree twisting around him like an old
man's gnarled arms the great sword ice
lay across Lord Eddard's lap and he was
cleaning the blade with an oil cloth
Winterfell
ran whispered his father looked up who's
there
he asked turning in bran frightened
pulled away his father in the black pole
and the godswood faded and were gone and
he was back in the cavern in the pale
thick roots of his weirwood throne
cradling his limbs as a mother does a
child tell us what she saw from far away
Leif looked almost a girl no older than
brain or one of his sisters but close at
hand she seemed far older she claimed to
have seen 200 years branes throat was
very dry he swallowed winterfell I was
back in Winterfell I saw my father he's
not dead he's not I saw him he's back at
Winterfell he's still alive no said Leif
he is gone boy do not seek to call him
back from death but said bran he heard
me he heard a whisper on the wind a
rustling amongst the leaves blood Raven
doesn't think that Ned can actually hear
what brain said but he does admit that
Ned heard something because Ned did
obviously give a reaction when bran
whispered the word Winterfell blood
Raven says he heard a whisper on the
wind a rustling amongst the leaves we
see something like this happen in the TV
show as well when Ned is right outside
of the tower of joy bran calls out for
his father and Ned does hear something
what's in the tower that's enough for
one day
visit again another time I want to see
where he's going
time to go brother
[Music]
now did any of you notice the look on
blood Ravens face when bran called out
to his father blood Raven says that Ned
cannot hear him but look at the reaction
he has when bran yells for Ned
bloodraven looks very concerned as if he
knows brain can be heard and Brian may
use that power to affect things later on
what's in the tower that's enough for
one day visit again another time I want
to see where he's going
time to go brother
now let's take a look at something else
that happened to John right around the
time John was traveling beyond the wall
of corn - they stopped for the night to
get some sleep when John tries to go to
sleep he begins to dream but what is
actually happening is John slips inside
of ghost when John does that something
very interesting happens when John is
inside of ghost brain begins to speak to
him when ghost is standing in front of a
weirwood tree beyond the wall check this
out when he closed his eyes he dreamed
of direwolves
there were five of them when there
should have been six and they were
scattered
each apart from the others he felt a
deep ache of emptiness a sense of
incompleteness the forest was vast and
cold and they were so small so lost his
brothers were out there somewhere and
his sister but he had lost their scent
he sat on his haunches and lifted his
head to the darkening sky and his cry
echoed through the forest a long lonely
mournful sound as it died away he
pricked up his ears listened for an
answer
but the only sound was the sigh of
blowing snow John the call came from
behind him softer than a whisper but
strong to can a shout be silent he
turned his head searching for his
brother for a glimpse of a lean gray
shape moving beneath the trees but there
was nothing only a weirwood remember
what was said right there John heard
someone whisper his name and he thought
it was his brother he turned his head
searching for his brother for a glimpse
of a lean gray shape moving beneath the
trees but there was nothing only a
weirwood it seemed to sprout from solid
rock it's pale roots twisting up from a
myriad of fissures and hairline cracks
the tree was slender compared to the
other where woods he had seen no more
than a sapling yet it was growing as he
watched its limbs thickening as they
reached for the sky weary he circled the
smooth white trunk until he came to the
face red eyes looked at him fierce eyes
they were yet glad to see him the
weirwood had his brother's face had his
brother always had three eyes not always
came the silent shalt not before the
crow he sniffed at the bark smelled wolf
and tree and boy but behind that there
were other scents the rich brown smell
of warm earth and the hard grey smell of
stone in something else
something terrible death he knew he was
smelling death he cringed back his
cerebral lling and bared his fangs don't
be afraid I like it in the dark no one
can see you but you can see them but
first you have to open your eyes
see like this and the tree reached down
and touched him so as you can see that
makes the second time brain is trying to
communicate with the use of the weirwood
trees now let's take a look at another
example this time brain tries to
communicate with theon greyjoy this is
of course when Theon is reak and he's in
winter fells godswood in front of the
weirwood tree Theon found himself
wondering if he should say a prayer will
the old gods hear me if I do they were
not his gods have never been his gods
he was Ironborn a son of Pyke his God
was the drowned God of the islands but
Winterfell was long leagues from the sea
it had been a lifetime since any God had
heard him he did not know who he was or
what he was or why he was still alive
why he had ever been born beyond a voice
seemed to whisper his head snapped up
who said that all he could see were the
trees and the fog that covered them the
voice had been as faint as rustling
leaves as cold as hate a gods voice or a
ghost that happens again when Theon
finds himself back out in the godswood
but this time it's more clear as to
whose voice Theon heard whisper the
night was winless the snow drifting
straight down out of a cold black sky
yet the leaves of the heart tree were
rustling his name Theon they seemed to
whisper Theon the old gods he thought
they know me they know my name I was
Theon of house Greyjoy I was a ward of
Eddard Stark a friend and brother to his
children
a leaf drifted down from above brushed
his brow and landed in the pole it
floated on the water read five-fingered
like a bloody hand bran the tree
murmured they know the gods know they
saw what I did and for one strange
moment it seemed as if it were brands
face carved into the pale trunk of the
weirwood staring down at him with eyes
red and wise and said brands ghost he
thought but that was madness so as you
can see as we get deeper into the books
brain begins to lie
on how to use his powers now if you want
to say feel and has lost his damn mind
from all the torture then go right ahead
but we know this is brand because this
isn't the first time he has done this we
saw him do this with Ned Stark and Jon
Snow in the books now I find it
interesting that Bloodraven tries to
tell a brand that they can't hear what
he is saying but in my opinion that look
on his face when bran called out to Ned
was very telling like I said earlier if
Ned could not hear what bran was saying
then why the hell did Bloodraven look so
concerned now let's bring this all the
way back around to the scene when John
finds Ghost what actually made John turn
around that day was a Bloodraven that
was influencing that events was at
John's connection to ghost or was it
actually brand that called out to John
and made him turn back remember when
John says can't you hear it
the very first thing bran notices is the
wind rustling through the trees why are
we told that I think there may be some
significance to these small details now
I know what some of you might be
thinking you might be thinking there
isn't anywhere wood trees around when
they find the direwolves that day so how
could bran have affected something in
that location well let's take a look at
something Bloodraven said to brand when
he took him inside of the weirwood net
for the very first time
bloodraven says once you have mastered
your gift you may look where you will
and see what the trees have seen be it
yesterday or last year or a thousand
days past a weirwood will live forever
if left undisturbed to them seasons pass
in a flutter of a moss swing in past
present and future or one nor will your
sight be limited to your gods would the
singers carve dyes into their heart
trees to awaken them and those are the
first eyes the new green seer learns to
use but in time you will see well beyond
the trees themselves that last sentence
right there is the key the first set of
eyes a new green seer learns how to use
as the where woods eyes but after some
training which brain is now currently
going through brain will eventually
learn to see without having to use the
weirwood trees bran will learn how to
see well beyond the trees themselves
that's why I think it was brand from the
future assisting John with finding
ghosts when the winds of winter or a
dream of spring comes out we will
continue to see brain training
inside a blood Ravens cave and there
will come a time when brain learns how
to harness his powers and look for time
without needing to use the weirwood
trees just like Bloodraven said they're
welcome as seen when brain goes back and
looks at the very beginning of the story
the day him and his brothers found the
dire wolf pups in the late summer snows
as brain begins to watch this scene play
out he will notice that they are leaving
before John is able to find ghosts as
Bryan watches them get half way across
the bridge he's gonna call out to John
in a whisper this will be the sound of
the wind moving through the trees that
bran hears that day when he is still a
boy not knowing that it was actually
himself making the wind move through the
trees causing John to turn around and
find ghosts
he had me maybe he had me
[Music]
you
[Music]
you
[Music]